who does a better white guy voice Dave
Chappelle or Eddie Murphy they both have
they're masterful for me it's Chappelle
I love his white guys his chip his buddy
chip yeah
somebody's doing The Cup now get the
hell out of here now he's at a level
where he almost just like it I know it's
prepared but it doesn't even feel
prepared as he speaks it feels like it's
coming off the Dome and it's like he
speaks in art like they're structured to
it but you can't see it at all like you
don't even feel the setup or the punch
line it's just all like flowing together
when they announced Dave Chappelle
especially as a surprise I can't think
of a time when the crowd cheers harder
it's like we had this time where he
stepped away from Chappelle Show and
like he was gone for like 10 years dude
the balls to just walk away yeah you
know and be like yeah I'm good for a
while yeah and I know they're super
loaded so it seems easy but I don't
think that's easy when it's your whole
life and you're used to it so then when
they do come back you're so grateful to
them for coming back yeah like thank you
for giving us something again